bonsoir maurice lemoine merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france est-ce
que ça sonne un petit peu ce retour
comme une revanche pour evo morales ce
que c'est qu'une revanche j'utiliserai
peut-être peut-être passe au bon
maintien en tout cas un retour de la de
la démocratie en bolivie puisqu'on a vu
pendant un an un gouvernement illégitime
sait on en parlait dans votre reportage
il ya eu effectivement un coup d'état de
bêtises 9 evo morales avait gagné
l'élection sont sablées corps avait été
remise en cause par l'organisation des
états américains bord mais elle a été
depuis démentie par un certain nombre de
chercheurs indépendants et donc
effectivement là la victoire de la
recette d'une manière assez paradoxale
d'ailleurs ou intéressante il ya un choc
là des des événements
le retour du mouvement vers le
socialisme en bolivie correspond
coïncide avec ce qui se passe
actuellement aux etats-unis où le
président donald trump est en grande
difficulté c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
et il ya la guitare un tout un symbole
puisque les états unis avaient appuyé le
coup d'état contre lebron
ce retour à des morales en bolivie est
ce que ça met fin aux accusations de
fraude électorale à son encontre
bah écoute et oui le sous-sol de
l'actuel président notre choix s'est
bien évidemment conteste tout à fait
cette cette accusation de fraude
électorale à l'époque par ailleurs la
dernière élection où il a gagné avec 55%
des voix relève toute équivoque sur le
fait que le mouvement vers le socialisme
mas est majoritaire dans le temps dans
le pays alors on va le phénomène ou là
on l'a vu dans notre reportage qui est
tout à fait similaire à ce qui se passe
aux etats unis c'est à dire que le
l'extrême droite la plus radicale
conteste le résultat d'élections domaine
que donald trump aux états unis est en
train de créer une situation absolument
incapable acadabrantesque comme aurait
dit à nos anciens présidents alors que
manifestement il a perdu aujourd'hui
clairement evo morales dit qu'il veut
arrêter la politique il veut se lancer
dans l'ue militantisme syndic
même faire de la pisciculture est ce
qu'on peut y croire selon vous alors il
va pas et bien évidemment il ne va pas
arrêter la politique simplement il ya un
des bras et il peut il a une proposition
indique très clairement que le président
élu de la bolivie ça n'est plus evo
morales c'est luis arce et un don qu'il
ne pas faire de l'ombre à son successeur
cela étant depuis sa sa province à
province de chine aurait déjà parlé il
va garder bien évidemment avoir un rôle
politique puisqu'il demeure président du
mouvement vers le socialisme mas le
parti qui est actuellement au pouvoir et
que il compris dans le nouvel homme
nouveau gouvernement où les nouvelles
institutions on va par exemple que le
nouveau président du sénat est un très
jeune en droit diko aurillac ce qui est
un projet clairement aujourd'hui louis
sarcelles va-t-il pouvoir s'affranchir
s'émanciper de son mentor je pense
qu'ils veulent faire de sûr on a on est
dans ce genre de situation dans une
oscillation qu'on connaît partout c'est
à dire que le dauphin doit très
clairement indiqué qu à partir de deux
d'aujourd'hui c'est lui le président
dans le registre lui c'est lui moi c'est
moi mais par ailleurs evo morales n'a
pas l'intention de faire de l'ombre à
celui qu'on appelle son dauphin qui a
été son ministre des colonies pendant
pendant une dizaine d'années et qui a
été appelé le leu leu l'artisan du
miracle bolivien est donc en principe la
fois il ya en même temps en principe il
ya aucune difficulté dans ce sens vous
pariez par deux fois vous avez fait
allusion à cette élection américaine est
ce que ça peut changer quelque chose
justement sur la situation politique en
bolivie et notamment pesé sur d'une
manière ou d'une autre sur evo morales
ah ben ça change de certains autres
choses en amérique latine il ya un
symbole éclatant c'est que le ministre
des affaires étrangères du venezuela
avec la présidente dé facto avait rompu
les relations
le mille saveurs étrangères est venu
donc à l'intronisation de miss archers
et il a repris possession de l'ambassade
du venezuela en bolivie en enlevant le
portrait du président autoproclamé roi
l'eau elle savait que d'aller dans les
équilibres géopolitiques latino
américains on a à la modification du pos
du panorama puisque on a souvent parlé
d'un d'une fin de cycle en amérique
latine en considérant que la gauche
était en train de s'effondrer
or on a vu la gauche au centre-gauche
revenir en argentine revenir au mexique
le venezuela résiste la bolivie
maintenant revient à gauche
peut-être demain 2021 l'équateur
passera-t-il lui aussi à gauche au
centre gauche et est donc effectivement
en face aux états unis on a là une
remontée en puissance de la gauche
latino américaine avec peut-être
travailler très prochainement à la
remise en action de l'union des nations
sud américaines qui avaient été qui a
été détruite par les gouvernements
conservateurs de mauricio macri en
argentine ball sonar au brésil le sonar
ou d'ailleurs qui se retrouve très
isolée maintenant avec la perte à la
fois jeanine et agnès en bolivie mais
surtout celle de donald trump aux états
unis le retour de morales sur le seul
bolivien est perçu comme ans dans son
ensemble on a vu quelques scènes de joie
mais surtout le pays
ça donne quoi va écouler ses manières
très très classique il ya évidemment ça
va provoquer l'enthousiasmé de ceux qui
pendant 14 ans grâce à sa présidence ont
vu leur situation s'améliorer et sava
enragé ceux qui ont organisé le coup
l'état l'an dernier et qui voir venir
celui qui était le leur comme en irlande
la bête au ni celle qu'il fallait
chasser
merci à vous maurice lemoine journal
spécialiste de l'amérique latine d'avoir
été avec nous pour vous exprimer sur ce
retour au pays d'evo morales merci à
vous